good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight hope you had a great and
relaxing thanksgiving weekend away from
the endless drone of news
if you somehow managed to pull that off
a few days of peace and happiness with
the ones you love
you found it was like a spa treatment
and you're obviously better off for it
but you also may be wondering what
happened what did you miss over the
weekend and we're here to tell you
for starters joe biden broke his foot in
a couple of places it sounds serious but
don't worry about it
biden was just out playing with his dog
as healthy vibrant adults in full
command of their faculties and not at
all fragile and fading
often do it could have happened to
anyone seriously it's totally
normal cnn in fact wrote a piece
congratulating biden for it
biden's injuries are far better than
donald trump's so don't ask questions
you've got
bigger stories to worry about in the
news landscape
for example did you hear that joe biden
picked women to lead the white house
communications office
that was a historic moment nothing like
that has happened in this country since
the presidency of donald trump
another triumph for the forces of
identity systemic sexism finally in
retreat
nothing can stop joe biden from smashing
the glass ceiling not even his dog so
that's what you missed
oh and one other thing the country's
public health establishment has tortured
your children for eight months
for no apparent reason that happened
that story has not received a lot of
coverage but it's been confirmed tonight
the authorities have admitted it 60
million
american children languishing in their
rooms since spring
sitting in front of screens learning
nothing isolated from human contact in
many cases
driven to mental illness we can now
report there was no reason for
any of that the experts were wrong
they had no idea what they were doing
but the most amazing part and this
really is the headline of the story
is that they knew they were wrong when
they did it
but they kept lying about it even as
american children began to kill
themselves
on sunday in new york city officials all
but admitted this
they announced they're reopening
elementary schools those are the same
schools that they closed fewer than two
weeks ago
now from a medical standpoint nothing
has changed
new york didn't get an early shipment of
the pfizer vaccine
there wasn't some groundbreaking new
research paper that revolutionized our
understanding of the chronovirus nothing
like that at all
in fact parents simply had enough and
they forced bill de blasio to admit the
obvious
this virus is not a threat to children
as de blasio put it in that weird
euphemistic way that dumb people speak
quote we know that the health realities
for the youngest kids are the most
favorable
well yes we do know that we've known her
for a long time we knew it when bill de
blasio shut down new york schools
and tony fauci knew it too though he
didn't say anything about it
now he's decided to say something about
it eight months late
here's anthony fauci on sunday and as
you watch this keep in mind that this
man
on the screen is leading our response
america's response
to the coronavirus close the bars and
keep the schools open is what we really
say
obviously you don't have one size fits
all but as i said in the past
and as you accurately quoted me the
default position
should be to try as best as possible
within reason
to keep the children in school or to get
them back to school
if you look at the data the spread among
children and from children
is not really very big at all not like
one would have suspected
oh i've always said you should keep the
schools open
says the man in charge of america's
coronavirus response to a nation whose
schools have been closed for months
right yeah i always said that check the
tape because quote if you look
at the data says anthony fauci
but wait a second why is this just now
occurring
to tony fauci isn't this fauci's entire
job to quote look at the data
yes it is and yet somehow he never
thought to do that
that's our coronasaur over the summer
when the data
looked the same as they do tonight fauci
explained that he couldn't really say
if kids should be allowed to go to
school it was quote complicated
except it wasn't complicated it wasn't
complicated then it's not complicated
now
in april many months ago a study by the
journal of the american medical
association
found that school-aged children who get
the coronavirus quote
develop only mild symptoms and typically
recover within two weeks
months later same story in june a study
in the lancet affirmed this quote
coven 19 is generally a mild disease in
children
including in infants other studies found
the exact same thing no study has found
anything but that
there was never much question about it
but if you're looking for more evidence
check the death rates those are publicly
available deaths are not hard to track
consider the state of new jersey that's
one of the states hit hardest by the
coronavirus
so far in new jersey not a single
school-aged child has died from the
coronavirus not
one many children have died from car
accidents
and fires and drug ods and suicide none
have died from covid19 in california the
biggest state
in the united states 40 million people
live there a total of
two people under the age of 18 have died
from the coronavirus two
the numbers nationwide according to the
latest cdc numbers
123 americans under the age of 18
have died from the coronavirus 123 out
of 350 million
we shut the schools anyway crushing
millions of kids
affecting their futures in ways we can't
even understand at this point but it's
clear it's bad
really bad in some cases so the question
is why do we do this and the answer is
to save the teachers the teachers unions
push this
and their servants in the democratic
party obey they're the single largest
donors to the democratic party so of
course they did
so unionized teachers get to stay home
collecting checks for their nine
month-to-year jobs
these classrooms are just too dangerous
it's like the battle of the bulge
five days a week and that's exactly what
they've done
but what do the data say about this
well for teachers under the age of 50
and that's the vast majority of them
the odds of surviving a coronavirus
infection are roughly
99.98
but we should tell you that for teachers
under 70 the risk of dying escalates to
a terrifying
99.5 percent chance of survival
and by the way if teachers do get sick
it likely won't be from teaching
children appear not to spread the
coronavirus certainly not effectively
we've known this for a long time back in
may researchers in europe found quote
children do not appear to be drivers of
transmission
and we argue that reopening schools
should be considered safe
accompanied by certain measures again
none of this
is new tony fauci the data guy
knew it at the time and so did anyone in
the news media who could read which is
still most of them
and yet they kept lying about it all of
them
in july here's just one example a panel
of physicians and experts on infectious
disease went on television to explain
that going to school isn't dangerous for
anyone they would send their
own kids watch the news anchors reaction
would you let your kids go back to
school i will
my kids are looking forward to it yes
period absolutely absolutely
as much as i can without a hesitation
without a hesitation yes i have no
concerns about sending my child to
school in the fall
i would let my kids go back to school dr
john torres
nbc news
they all said yes
they all said yes says newsreader
feigning shock can you believe that
doctors have concluded their own
children should go to school they must
be crazy
they're crazy what do the doctors know
about coronavirus
what was this about and of course you
know the answer it was about donald
trump
donald trump in this case agreed with
the doctors therefore the doctors had to
be mocked
and ignored here's what the president
said about schools in july
we have to open our schools open
our schools stop this
nonsense we open our schools
stop this nonsense we reopen our schools
now in point of fact as a scientific
matter that turned out to be
sound policy based on sound data
but the media told us the exact opposite
of that one headline at cnn warned of
quote
the very clear dangers of donald trump's
push to reopen schools
google didn't censor that as
misinformation it should have another
headline called out
donald trump's mind-bending logic on
school reopening
mind-bending logic those damn data again
joe biden's campaign didn't want to hear
it they didn't want you to hear it
either
school was dangerous period
donald trump claimed the opposite
therefore it was too dangerous to send
your kids or for you to decide to send
them
watch ignoring how the virus spreads
risking teachers and parents lives going
against the advice of experts
very little impact on young people
do you trust him to do what's best for
our children because this
is not a test
yeah going against the advice of experts
in this country that's no longer allowed
even and maybe especially when the
experts are completely wrong
what's the message the message couldn't
be clearer they're not your kids anymore
if they were your kids you could make
the key decisions about their lives but
they're not
those kids your former kids belong to
tony fauci now
tony fauci america's parent he'll make
the decisions about your kids thank you
very much
in conjunction with the nation's uber
mom who by the way is also 80 years old
mrs nancy d pelosi watch mrs pelosi fred
about the health of
our children are you confident
that students and teachers will go back
safely to school in the fall
no i think what we heard from the
secretary was malfeasance
and and dereliction of duty this is
appalling they're messing
they're messing the president and his
administration are messing
with the health of our children going
back to school
is presents the biggest risk for the
spread
of the coronavirus
there's if that's not criminal what she
just said
we may need to redefine what it means to
commit a crime
60 million school-age children affected
by a decision that was wrong
and many of them hurt for life but we
just blow right past it
and allow political leaders like that to
blow right past with phrases like the
health of our children
what happens when you lock children in
their rooms in front of screens and
prevent them
from experiencing human contact has
nancy pelosi ever been
asked that question has she ever
wondered about the answer
according to the centers for disease
control a total of 522 children between
the ages of 5 and 14
died of suicide in 2017.
in that same age group only 42 children
have
died from the coronavirus so far this
year
what are those suicide numbers going to
look like if we continue to take nancy
pelosi's advice
about the health of our children we
already have some
indications of that future years will
reveal the whole picture
and you can be certain it'll be
horrifying but for right now
with incomplete data here's what we know
in st paul minnesota
for example 40 percent of all grades
given this year
have been fs and you can be certain
they're grading lightly but it's still
double the normal amount of failures in
fairfax county virginia the number of
middle and high school students with
failing grades in two or more classes
has increased by 83 percent the number
of students with disabilities who are
failing two or more classes has
increased by more than
100 percent in a lot of school districts
huge numbers of kids never even
registered for online classes
do you have kids do you know anyone who
does they're learning nothing
those are real consequences if you want
to know the health of a society
look at its young people look at its
schools
these are obvious points that are being
roundly ignored and anyone who makes
them is attacked for making them
we're going to look back on this moment
in shame
back in june we interviewed dr scott
atlas he was then a member of the white
house's chronovirus
task force he was one of the very few
people then or now
brave enough to make a simple point
here's what he said but the point about
the schools is really critical because
this is the most
irrational public policy probably in in
modern history
children have virtually zero risk of
getting a serious complication virtually
zero risk of dying you don't lock down
the children because
you are personally afraid it's totally
outrageous
dr scott atlas was attacked as a monster
for saying that
really attacked dr tony fauci
by contrast was deified signs throughout
northwest dc said i believe dr fauci but
the truth
is that scott atlos was right and dr
fauci
was revealed as a power mad incompetent
that's not our opinion by the way the
data prove it